joining me now is Dr Bharat pankanya a
an expert in infectious disease very
good morning to you
411 days testing positive have you ever
heard anything like this before
it's not impossible it's unusual but not
impossible and by the way this is clear
this is good biology in action so this
person was immune suppressed and as a
result of being immune suppressed they
had this Persistence of infection and I
have seen many of these uh incidents in
for example TB when their immune
suppressed the infection carries on
without doing much damage to the lungs
but it can still be there so it is
possible biologically
and and there's no medicine to cure
covert per se is there so what kind of
treatment did he receive and how much
difference did that make
so he was given the whole uh our
momentum antivirals uh antibodies uh and
what has worked is that he had the
original old uh version of the virus
against which the antibodies made in the
laboratory worked and eventually he was
cured so the important Point here is if
we imagine that the uh the spikes on the
virus are the nuts and the antibodies
are the spanners then if the nuts change
shape the spanners will not fit and work
so the new variants that we have Omicron
Etc they are not attacked properly by
the uh the anti-antibodies that we have
uh made and they are therefore not
working anymore so we would have to go
back to the laboratory and make a
version of antibodies that work against
the circulating Omicron Forex example
and are treatments like this still
considered experimental or are we
getting a real idea now of how people
with persistent or serious cases can be
treated
no we're learning every day and whilst
we started off as Pioneers we know a lot
more about how to tackle this and we're
getting better and better at it so
remember we've got uh the uh the
steroids then we got the antiviral drugs
and then we've got the antibodies so we
are getting much much better compared to
two years ago
and what about understanding why some
people get the disease more seriously
and some get it for longer do we have a
real understanding of what it is that
that are the factors in determining that
no that's a still work in progress and
it is very important to understand that
Immunology because some people get that
infection recover end of story and some
people get that infection the infection
goes but the immune system carries on
overreacting and then you get this
incidence of what we call brain fog
tiredness and generally being unwell and
then we have to end up suppressing that
immune system so a lot to learn but
we're learning but we haven't cracked it
all together
very briefly uh former Health secretary
during the time of covid Matt Hancock is
going on I'm a celebrity quick thought
on what you make of that
and it's very disappointing because I
personally was involved in all this and
I feel uh you know nursing homes people
died uh there were this VIP contracts
their failure of PPE so much so I feel
very disappointed that Matt Hancock
seems to have put all those failings
behind him and he's off on a new career
okay we must leave it there Dr Bharat
pacmania very interesting to talk to you
this morning we really appreciated thank
you